des systèmes
ne vous fiez pas à leur posture
tranquille et décontractée le vélo
couché est une vraie discipline sportive
inventé après guerre ce n'est donc pas
une nouveauté
son développement est récent et à la
réunion il est apparu seulement cette
année sur les routes de l'île
le vélo couché depuis les années 1930
inventé par monsieur moshe pour le deux
roues couché et a fallu attendre des
années 90 pour avoir le trois roues
couché se développer appelée trike outre
et c'est la raison pour laquelle
entretenir centre en 1990 et s'est rien
passé c'est qu'il y avait des enjeux
économiques vis-à-vis du vélo
traditionnel qui ont empêché l'union
cycliste internationale de valider les
records détenus par les deux roues
couché
bien installé dans une position
confortable le vélo couché permet
pourtant des pointes de vitesse
supérieure à un vélo classique avec des
records à plus de 90 km heure
on assistait donc un développement plus
important du vélo couché en métropole
dans les années 90 et celui de la
réunion nous sommes donc les premiers
depuis cinq mois à faire connaître cette
activité un meilleur rendement grâce au
pédalage horizontale meilleur confort
grâce aux doubiens soutenu le vélo
couché a conquis pas mal d'adeptes du
vtc ou du vélo classique donc le vélo
couché à 3o permet plusieurs
utilisations de la route au tout chemin
pour monter
quel que soit le type de corte et pour
descendre à petite vitesse la grande
vitesse on a deux façons de choisi un
spot
le premier sera un parc où on va dire
axé sur le fun et la vitesse et les
sensations et le deuxième type de
parcours ont choisi c'est un parcours
beaucoup plus familial pour la
découverte et la balade
sabella
donc le vélo couché apporte des
sensations inconnues ce cas aujourd'hui
mais qui mélange un peu les âmes
pression qu'on aurait à bord d'un
karting donc des sensations de glisse à
ras le sol qui permettent en toute
stabilité de d'atteindre des vitesses
inavouables
on perd mais on perd mais aussi avec ses
vélos de jouer énormément avec le relief
de faire glisser l'arrière de bloquer
les roues
voilà donc une conduite on va dire
sportive
il est aussi idéal pour les longues
distances car il peut supporter de
lourds bagages sans déséquilibrer son
cavalier le vélo couché ne demande
aucune notion d' équilibre les personnes
qui savent qu'ils savent pas faire de
vélo peuvent s'initier la particularité
sera uniquement sur le type de parcours
qu'on va choisir qui sera plus exigeant
pour certaines personnes c'est d'autre
est là on adaptera en fonction de cette
personne